Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Let's get inspired by Dairy, Eye, Hair, Sideburns.
There's evidence of humans making cheese dating
back 7,500 years.
Dairy herding goes back 9,000 and it's believed
our ancestors were lactose intolerant so they
ate fermented foods like yogurt and cheese
which turn lactose into lactic acid.
And it was also easier to transport the protein-rich
cheese curd than milk.
The idea that eating carrots improves eyesight
is a myth originating from World War II.
The British developed a new radar system to
shoot down German planes at night but they
wanted to keep it a secret so they created
propaganda citing an excess of eating carrots
by their pilots as their reason for success.
Carrots do have beta carotene which converts
to Vitamin A - a lack of which could lead
to health problems but any well-rounded diet
will supply enough Vitamin A.
People started wearing powdered wigs because
of syphilis.
There was an epidemic in Europe and patchy
hair loss was one of the symptoms so the wigs
were needed to cover up the rampant baldness.
The powder was scented with orange and lavender
to cover the odor of the accompanying sores
and rashes.
Soon after, King Louis XIV and King Charles
II wore them to cover their thinning hair
and they started a trend that spread throughout
the aristocracy with the term "bigwig" coming
from those who could afford the biggest most
elaborate wigs.
Having facial hair on the side of the face
has been around since at least 100 BC and
we know this thanks to a mosaic featuring
Alexander The Great sporting the style but
the name sideburns comes from a U.S. Civil
War General - Ambrose Burnside.
He had facial hair across his cheeks that
connected to his mustache and it became known
as burnsides.
Sideburns came into style a few years later
by shaving the mustache leaving you with just
the burns on the side.
Now if we take out the air like this, the
ey, s and burns what we're left with is Dye
and Hide.
An Easter Egg tradition.
Humans have been decorating eggs for millennia
with engraved ostrich eggs discovered in Africa
going back 60,000 years.
Christians of Mesopotamia stained eggs red
in tribute to the blood of Christ and the
egg itself represents the resurrection of
the Lord.
But modern adults rank red as the least popular
color with their favorite being blue.
And as always - thanks for watching.